in this workshop what we're going to do
is talk about the kinds of people who we
wind up having difficulties with in the
workplace what what's the story
techniques insight strategies where that
might be I should mention that we won't
be doing the role-playing part at the
end in part because you notice that
there's actually two people here instead
of just one my wife and partner in
zhanka she and I built the workshop
together she unfortunately through some
health issues was was not cleared for
travel so that was sort of a big setback
in the workplace already but she's been
thinking a lot about this you know
workplace issues I've been thinking
quite a bit about this over my time and
says this year the theme was stoicism
and work I thought this is the ideal so
if you if you want to fill out the stuff
you can if not you don't have to there's
a little bit of pre-work and that could
be useful will use as discussion points
here and there the key issue that we are
talking about is of course difficult
people not just all workplace matters
but difficult people in particular and
we can talk about other things and what
strategy as a person might use for
dealing with different issues but we're
going to try to stick with the person
the interpersonal the people who really
rile us up the people a lot of troubles
for us the people who
all right what we're going to do is is
first I want to talk a little bit about
certain challenges for applying stoicism
at all in the workplace maybe some of
you have run into these and you've been
working for things maybe some of these
will occur to you as you try to apply it
so it's ism maybe you've already got
these handle and in in any case we're
gonna we're going to go through some of
those challenges then we'll talk about
common types of people who present
challenges in the workplace and what
I've got for you after that is mostly
talking about the particular stoic
practices some are very short-term what
you can do in a situation that's
presenting you with challenges some are
more longer-term dealing the things you
can do over time to sort of prepare
yourself and we're going to do a
role-playing exercise potentially this
room would not be good for anyway so it
turns out that that's you know in some
ways fortuitous the entities not here
but what we want to do is talk through a
couple issues common common things
there'll be time for that I think so
challenges that that you face in the
workplace if you're thinking in terms of
stoicism particularly if you're sort of
new to it and you've heard things like
well only virtue counts all these other
things are different they're externals
they're not in our control then we throw
you for a bit of a loop when you get in
the workplace because what are all the
things that we deal with in the
workplace besides our own motivation and
our behavior they're all externals right
how much money we actually get paid our
wages that's an external from the stoic
perspective does it mean that we we
should then say uh doesn't really matter
to me if my boss keeps saying no to me
getting a legitimate raise or if there
me for overtime but not paying before no
it doesn't actually mean that and there
might be a bit of cognitive dissonance
and trying to think about how we apply
slug theory to situations like that let
me give you a bunch of they say you find
yourself in one yeah thanks very much
for doing that
absolutely so you know these matters are
like I said externals and we get this
counsel that well we shouldn't we
shouldn't care about them we shouldn't
be emotionally invested in them what are
they well wealth is one our bodies are
another you know the workplace does take
stress or a toll on our body you know
we're sitting in a chair doing whatever
else it is that we do all day long a lot
of repetitive motions reputation plays a
role in the workplace the positions that
we get or don't get all of those sorts
of things how people treat us is is you
know much of what we're experiencing
another issue that we might think about
is our roles you know when we're
practicing our roles like if you think
about when Epictetus tells us that all
of our duties are you know defined by
the roles that we have does that mean
that that's all we are and if we're
being good Stoics we're going to just
sort of suck it up when everybody treats
us kind of kind of badly you don't think
about retail right
especially the holiday season that's
getting closer if you work in retail or
you work in a restaurant or anything
like that the service industries you
know how how people can be maybe we have
to be a bit self protective the stoicism
actually give us good guidance on that
or is it if we practice it is it setting
us up to be exploited to be treated
badly these are think of some real
challenges that face people in trying to
apply this stuff in the workplace so my
answer is no it actually doesn't send us
something
if it's properly understood and applied
but if it's kind of you know cookie
cutter just a little you know a few
passages kind of saw us isn't it
probably is setting us up for that sort
of thing
another issue that that's quite
important to think about is justice what
do each of us deserve what do people
have a legitimate reason to ask from us
and what what becomes illegitimate then
we even have unfortunately some people
who aren't abusive to us in the
workplace it's not actually stoic to
just put up with abuse for the sake of
putting up with abuse I know that that
Epictetus can tell us or marcus aurelius
oh they're not really hurting you
because you you know only you can hurt
yourself that's not exactly true and the
Stoics were incredibly concerned about
making sure that things are actually
just if you read we were talking about
sister was on duties just before this if
you read sister was on duties which is a
very systematic treatise of stoic ethics
he devotes a lot of discussion to what
people actually know each other and i
think he wasn't talking about the
workplace but we can apply much of that
to the workplace the other thing that i
think can really be a challenge for
people and all sort of open enough to
look what you guys think is challenging
is the fact that other people are not
gonna be stars so if you start
practicing stoicism in the workplace
first of all don't tell anybody
I mean epictetus tells me that right off
the bat right if you don't don't call
yourself a philosopher don't tell people
you've got a new you know self health
regimen just start doing it and then see
how it how it works because what happens
if you tell people exactly they're gonna
they're gonna be like ah is this this
person is doing something new I'm gonna
provoke them and then after a bit how's
your stoicism now you know and then
you're gonna feel pretty pretty bad and
it's gonna make things more difficult
for you it's rational not to tell other
people that you're doing that that's why
epictetus gives you this advice and
sooner or later we have to come to try
with the fact that and I think this is
part of you know the stoicism that other
people are not going to change in our
environment if they do it's pretty rare
at the PETA strikes about how Socrates
who you know this great teacher he was
successful maybe one in a thousand times
maybe one in a thousand people listened
to him and if you know if you look about
how many people are in Athens and how
many of them became his followers that's
probably about an accurate number you
know he had playing were quoted Killip
in his trial so what what issues those
of you who are trying to practice
stoicism in the workplace besides these
what else presents challenges for you
just the whole idea about being a stoic
in the workplace any issues yeah I think
one I have trouble balancing the most is
people who respond to acquiescence
versus people to respond to more
aggressive personalities got bosses
really I like this guy he takes what he
wants isn't it [ __ ] like there for
you
the average is a kind of box he says you
know what this guy built does what I
tell him to do
therefore I treat them better balancing
that and doing it without manipulation
and engine and honestly it's difficult
yeah and you can find yourself there's
their sort of uh you know almost like a
temptation right yeah you you you're
trying to be a good stomach you respond
saying anger because you're tired of
dealing with people's be us suddenly
everyone's like oh we're gonna back off
we're gonna treat this guy right and
then you know you're faced with a real
challenge you say you know I actually
back slid I probably shouldn't do this
but it seems to be effective you know
again I should mention Cicero in in on
duties we've mark was just talking about
this book three is devoted to when
you've got clashes between what's right
and what is expedient or what seems to
work is how we would put it so I think
that is a real significant challenge any
other challenges other people pose pose
you with the workplace yes
justice which this problem of times and
I was just promoted and I see I work
with young people and I get complaints
and so how to navigate like it makes me
so upset and angry but how to navigate
working with them to help them you know
do a better job without yeah and you
don't just want to say well you know
Epictetus tells us some things are in
our control other things aren't all
those other people failing on the job
and that's not in my control you feel
like you have this is where justice and
yeah I think that's a real challenge
yeah yeah so and that is something that
we see happening in like not just the
workplace but the Facebook Stoicism
group all the time right and so this
raises an interesting question
when's the great time to do it well how
does it house prudence counsel to do
that I think some people in order to
find this just in stoicism there's lots
of other available thing you like you
know you might summon up in this this
race actually you know there's a good
bit of that and then that's not
particularly helpful figuring out when
to say the right thing at the right time
very helpful right so sometimes
determining that can be
big challenge let's talk about the kinds
of people who would tick us off
who aggravated ifficult
right I have a whole list here for you
that you may have others to add to this
list and I think part of what we want to
think about as we look at these is what
makes these people difficult for us you
know we can we can associate them with
types and we're not we're not
stereotyping people by doing that or if
we say that somebody is you know
contentious and argumentative hey the
ancient Stoics who would tell us don't
get too upset about that also have no
problem calling people out for being
contentious and argumentative there's
you know there's actually words for it
in the in the ancient Greek so we want
to think about what makes these people
difficult for us personally and then
also difficult in general we can find
people who are difficult for us in
pretty much any role in the workplace so
it could be our boss or it could be we
have employees our employees or our
direct reports it could be our
co-workers it could be students yeah it
could be clients
it could be patients could be customers
right
it could be suppliers it can be you name
it could be somebody who you have to
deal with in some government bureaucracy
already get a permit to do something any
one of these people control in one of
these these roles and the other thing I
wanted to point out too is well there's
two things I want to point out one is
that not everyone is going to find all
these people difficult because we have
different temperaments some of us may
find some of these people just really
irritating and we're okay with others I
know I'm a more contentious person
myself the Greeks would call it being
bubonic you know having that that sort
of agra agra veda
side when it makes me impatient during
meetings that makes certain of these
people harder for me to deal with and
certainly a lot easier to do it and
you're all going to have
challenges like that as well so this
list doesn't necessarily not necessarily
the list for every single person the
other thing is that some difficult
people actually have multiple roles we
could say because they can be you know
more difficult than than others so look
at some of these you know chronically
negative people this is a big one there
are there people who complain all the
time nothing is ever good enough in the
workplace you know you put in a coffee
machine well why isn't this flavored
coffee right why isn't it tea coffee
isn't very good
we should have filtered the water you
know they go on and on and on and that
that can wear on you over time
drama kings and queens somebody do that
have these in your office by this I mean
people the one who not only want to be
on stage but they want you to be part of
their drama as a bit player this is
something bullies sadists and abusers
this this is a real significant problem
there are people who are quite abusive
in the workplace and it takes a lot of
different forms the unduly demanding I
wrote a piece in stoicism today about
this recently by this I mean the kind of
people it's not just that the conditions
are never good enough it's that your
work product or your performance is
never good enough and they may even say
it to you in very nice ways but they
always want a little bit more out of you
you know this this is this is really
they do the sandwich technique this is
really great stuff here's my notes now I
hope we have a nice meeting next time
alright but they're still just
constantly telling you that what you're
doing isn't isn't good enough
people with annoying traits or habits
this is probably a little bit easier to
deal with and this is much more personal
you know if like some people don't like
people spinning for example other people
don't really care about that I'm not
remember my mother would get very angry
if she saw a person spitting on the
sidewalk and I was like what do you
carry you know it's not hurting the
sidewalk but that was a thing for it for
her people who chew loudly and their
cubicle next two years people who leave
messes you know people who are too clean
sometimes
right and then we started to get some
other interesting ones that disorganized
the unprepared the flaky these are the
coworkers the Walter was talking about
cases of trying to get a co-worker to
work with you and you know when you if
any of you were students what is it that
students hate about group assignments
the other people yeah what about these
other people exactly and everybody it's
the same grade and there's always like
somebody who doesn't do their thing and
you've got to do it for them
well there's co-workers like that or
bosses sometimes you have to complete
the reports for your bosses you know
employees that you know you have to make
up for other things the greedy the
self-centered the exploitative this is
very common in ancient you know Greece
and Rome they had a word for play on
next yet wanting to have too much of the
stuff that should be shared by other
people the contentious and argumentative
these are people who really desired
victory they really desire being right
and this is this is a character type
Epictetus has a chapter about this in
the discourses and he sort of diagnoses
what's going on with them
entitled unmotivated lazy people people
who just aren't gonna it's not that
they're flaky and they can't get the job
done because they're distracted they
just don't feel like doing the job that
maybe some of the book yeah sometimes
it's a matter of burnout I think to you
know that might fit in that character in
that category the incompetent and
uncoachable if any of you have people
that you work with there are some people
who just can't get work done and they
may in fact have a job because you know
they're the owner's son or you know
nephew or or daughter or something like
that or you know they're unfavorable but
they just don't don't get worked up
the over social the hyper sharing and
gossipy any of these in your workplaces
people I always want to be talking about
other people or or you know what what's
happen
in a show or you know in the national
media the passive-aggressive this is a
real problem
I think rageaholics the oversensitive
and other angry types people who have
general genuine anger problems
stoicism I think it's helpful for
dealing with that but have you ever read
that passage and Epictetus where a guy
comes to Epictetus and says hey my
brothers mad at me you know what can I
do about Isis nothing have your brother
come to me and I can work with your
brother but there's nothing that I can
tell you that's gonna make your brother
not angry at you I all I can do is tell
you how to deal with with the fact that
you backstabbers promise breakers the
unfaithful people who sell you out
bad influencers and enablers that's
that's an issue you know the people who
say you know we've really worked hard we
should go get a drink
you know it's Wednesday right don't wait
til that the weekend look at those those
things done and then the the team
builders the people who are always you
know talking about we but they really
mean I and it's their way and they're
they're trying to be controlling about
stuff they often have nice you know
agendas for you worked out in advance
maybe I'm you know I'm supposed to
actually do that for this workshop if
you came in here and it was just all you
know let's just do a rap session you
probably wouldn't feel you haven't got
your money's worth right but you know
there are some people who they're the
ones who always run the agenda right and
then I'm just helping everybody out now
how many of these people do find
annoying
or difficult or are they you know what
is it from a stoic perspective that
these people are doing to you what what
is the the outcome for you are you
losing your temper are you being less
productive
you finding yourself in certain
difficulties yeah over external that
that's true you you get make it extra
work there's a lot of these people that
can shift work on to the greedy will do
it because you know they they would
rather you have to do the work the lazy
will do it because they just don't you
do it the passive-aggressive may have
other other ways of doing it what can we
do actually before we do that
have I missed anybody are there other
people that you find other types yeah I
find I get a lot of people that say one
thing but they don't mean okay I uh I'm
a pretty literal person so I don't get
it
yeah when people say one thing but they
don't like that it's all [ __ ] yeah I
mean a prime example of that is when
people make plans and they're like hey
we're all gonna go out after work and
you know it's like 4:30 they're like
okay so I call the babysitter so I can
have you know my kid watch I'm ready to
go and they're like oh yeah we weren't
really serious yeah I know I think that
that would be an example of people who I
mean it's that might fit in sometimes
with some of these like flaky promise
yeah and and you know sometimes it's
deliberate so in there there my I was
just talking with a friend of mine who
was strung along for two months with the
promise of like a permanent position
he's working in a temp position at this
this call center and you know permanent
position was would come along they were
going to get him in there and of course
there was no position ever for two
months there's a supervisor like yeah
raisin steaks and saying what it is
worse that I've seen is lots of startups
that had a ton of potential to build a
great product to do something really
amazing or organizations of any type
I've seen a lot of them get it fizzle
out or get wasted because the team can't
work together or even worse through one
person on the team who ruins it for
everybody else and then the company
basically can't get the product out
because that one person has one of these
characteristics you know we were
actually just talking about that at
lunch there's the Internet is a
graveyard platforms that all showed
great promise and we were talking about
why why these fail and very often we
don't know you know we just know that
they they get an initial investment and
they seem to be like you know making
some advances and then suddenly nobody's
using it or it just doesn't grow and and
I think a lot of times it's it's it's
what you're talking about I mean it
could also be a failure in terms of
leadership as well and all these things
can we people in leadership positions
can be of these types as well yes I
don't experience these things that
extremes you know just enough that it's
kind of frustrating and Yap times not to
take action yeah
and that can be its own kind of
frustration where you're like I'll do
I'll say something if this person
crosses this line and they never do that
so you just got this constant
or yeah that could be a that could be
another type that people who give us
mixed messages they you know and
sometimes that might overlap too with
all right lying or being abusive the
people who are abusive and then want to
shower us with praise to try to make up
for the abuse so we don't we don't quit
or turn them in or things along those
lines any other types of you can think
of any other people that we I can have
been a few co-workers you if they
complain like you mentioned and then you
suggest well how about doing bad about
it they never used to act
that's an interesting case the people
who you there does seem to be some
genuine wish to change things this kind
of ties in with what you're talking
about people who aren't really literal I
think there's a lot of people who say
they want things to be different but
they don't really want things you don't
change they have an investment in things
can being the way they are where they
say well that's that other groups
responsibility I I can't do anything
about it even though there really is
something they could do about yeah and
this goes back to that issue that I
brought up as a challenge we can't
expect other people to be Stoics in the
workplace we can change ourselves we're
unlikely to get other people to change
and the workplace there may be some
places where it's more conducive and
we're likely to get people to want to
change like it like here for example
right we're all gathered here together
talking about stoicism presumably you
know some people will have a high
moments and they'll be like oh crap I
kind of need to work on this you know
you know Donald said this thing and now
it's parked this this thought my head
think about Massimo do it do I have any
a mafia but I need to worry about right
I think this is a conducive atmosphere I
don't know that the workplace in many
cases is and even the review processes
that we often have in place are not
particularly helpful with this you know
in many settings we review people once a
year I can tell you that actually when I
was still teaching University professor
full time we came up with this amazing
new review system where you would have
your student evaluations you have a
chair with you you'd have an outside
person come in and you would have all of
us you know professors reviewing each
other and it didn't take long before
about three-quarters of the departments
came to a tacit agreement that everybody
gets a five which is the top rating and
we're not gonna have to do it in this
peer review nonsense we'll just give
everybody a five with the occasional
four so that it doesn't flag anything
statistically because they're smart
they're professors right we actually
tried to take it seriously there were
six of us in the philosophy section it
took us hours to do this thing and
actually we got angry we didn't agree on
who was doing a good job who wasn't
doing a good job you know it was totally
ineffective as a review process and we
were only gonna do it once a year you
know so yeah the feedback and and
willingness to change all these are big
issues I think in the workplace yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's a couple ways
that can happen sometimes they just look
at you know like you're you're the
squeaky wheel so you know you're not
getting in grease you're getting you
know replaced sometimes they say I'm so
glad you brought that up with to me now
you have a new position you have a new
job description you're going to handle
this for me
you're not going to probably get paid
more for it but it'll be part of your
positions or they will sometimes you
bring up what somebody else is doing
they'll they'll end up defending that
person or yeah that's that's a big
problem and that can happen with
co-workers to you complain too this is
part of why you probably have to be
judicious and how you complain to
co-workers about fellow co-workers or
about the boss because they can always
say go around and tell that person what
you said so probably if you're thinking
in terms of Stoics you probably want to
be think am I really committed to this
and I'm not saying to be cynical but
that's that's I think that's part of
prudence let's talk about what you can
do as a stoic and this is where we get
to the second part and I think we're
have plenty of time for this some of
these for those of you that have been
studying this for a while some of these
are very familiar ideas maybe for some
of you less familiar and and maybe what
we'll do is since we do have you know a
good bit of time we're actually sort of
like on track when it comes to this is
if you have any questions about these
and how they would apply or comments if
you try them yourself just just bring
them up so dealing with appearances and
such right what is that referring to you
saw some of these quotes earlier on in
some of the plenary presentation
Epictetus saying when you encounter a
harsh appearance say to it you're only
an appearance and not what you pretend
to be
now that sounds really rather abstract
what the hell is he talking about
appearances
so in Greek yeah okay so maybe that's a
great example and I could take any
person this is entirely directed at the
earth against me then you saw me and
this is all about just games which is
foolishness yeah well you don't even
know I mean there's another appearance
there you don't even know that he thinks
he's the center of the earth Peter you
don't even know it's a he a lot of times
I'm like oh yeah all of those are what
what epictetus calls appearances and
Greek it's Fantasia and sometimes you'll
see it translated as impressions the
things that we we get and we're like
that's what's going on right and another
translation of it would be imagination
so the things that we imagine to
ourselves about what the real situation
is we don't often know we know some
things we know we know that we are
seeing this or we are hearing that we
don't often know what the intent behind
it is we don't know what the larger
picture is we don't know what the
significance of it is that doesn't mean
that we can't know that stuff but
sometimes we have to take a pause and
one way that we often get ourselves
quite upset is by carrying out an
automatic process of response and
thinking and you'll notice that it's not
just feelings
because we're the Stoics are
particularly strong it's not just
feelings like being angry or being sad
or being afraid there's always a
judgement there's always a cognitive
part to it and we can it takes time to
get used to this but we can distance
ourself a bit and then figure out what
is actually going on here so I think
that's that's that's a good example
a co-worker coming over and say spilling
your coffee and I just walk
right that looks like a jerk move but
maybe they really had to get to
someplace on time of a they're gonna
come back later and clean it up only to
find you at your desk like you know
turning your back you know ready to give
up the silent treatment something like
those I didn't even notice that they hit
that yeah we assumed so I so I ascribe
deliberation and deliberate action
they're not thinking about yeah so what
we can do in immediate situations and it
does take some practice is to tell
ourselves wait a second let's not jump
to conclusions here let's not you know
let the appearances tell us what's going
on let's try to figure out what's going
on Epictetus says apply the criterion
the criterion is just a touchstone so
there's different types of criteria for
different sort of situations you want to
know what's going on in there co-worker
maybe you asked I don't know you figure
that yeah like mr. Magoo
well mr. Magoo will cause a whole like
collision probably and the cartoons know
well any questions about that one before
comments anybody ever done that and
found it useful Network appearances
aren't what they seem like they say so
I'm so left because
that's not really oh you mean when
people quit yeah or the leader is gone
and they say okay decided to spend more
time with his family but yeah that's a
great euphemism politicians do that Tim
politicians I get themselves and
scandals always want to spend time with
family so that's an appearance it's not
reality yeah I mean and we want to be
careful
Epictetus isn't saying just because
something is an appearance that we can't
ever get to the bottom of it he actually
says reason itself is an entire system
of appearances that things like The
Iliad are a whole bunch of networked
appearances so we just have to be
careful with them the starts talk about
us human beings as having the facility
to make use of appearances and again
this sounds rather abstract but when we
put it into more concrete terms I think
it's very easy to relate to does that
make sense for everyone let's talk about
deconstructing things in their parts we
had an example of that earlier today
when forget who was brought up Marcus
Aurelius and the talking about the the
role that he was wearing Marcus Aurelius
himself carries this out several times
in his meditations he says look at the
food that you're eating realize it's
just you know dead stuff what's that
dissolves talk okay yeah yeah and so
that's that's what we're talking about
here the things mark Marcus says that if
we look at things and break them down
into their parts they lose some of their
their fascination over us they lose some
of their their capacity to cook you know
sort of drawing our desire or to provoke
our aversion to get us to choose them to
choose to try to reject them they lose
their their allure now he goes a little
bit far with that I think you know he's
talking about you know the food that
you're eating he talks about about sex
by the time that he gets done with it
they're they're really not something
interesting
are attractive at all maybe we ought to
go that far but it can be very helpful
for us when we find things are really
bothering us we have an aversion towards
them or they're really strongly
compelling our desire that we break them
down into what they really are you know
a great opportunity here that actually
appearances would be a good thing when
when you're presented with an
opportunity oftentimes that just means a
bare possibility of something being good
for you you don't really know what
you're getting into but if you if you
take the opportunities that you're
presented with and you break them down
to what will they actually provide me
with maybe they're not such a great
opportunity or when you think about the
bad things that are being presented by
other people like for example let's take
the person who's got the annoying habits
right you can hear them chewing I don't
know if this bothers you it bothers me
to hear somebody like next to me chewing
very loudly especially they like chew
with their mouths open and smack their
lips you know well one of my kids
sometimes has to be reminded not to do
that you know and we're I'm doing it so
that he doesn't do when he's when he's
older right now what is actually going
on there it's just a physical process
you know it's not something that really
has to bother me I don't know I
definitely don't have to like turn that
person into a you know loud sure that
that you know they're that they're the
bane of my existence but I can't get
work done because they're distracting me
so much I can deconstruct things this is
this one that makes sense for you this
is one again you can apply in the
situation takes practice because it's
not gonna occur to you immediately to do
yeah even in that situation let's say
you do structure
yes
starter they're chewing at the table so
you just construct it and you still ask
them not to chew oh sure so you didn't
deal with it in a way like yourself
learning to deal with the chewing and
accepting it
it's just perfume in I do that in part
because I don't want them to be ticking
off other people who art Starks all
right you know I want something good for
them yes well so because I have to raise
them I mean this is this is one of those
things where again I put it out at the
beginning the dichotomy of control
doesn't tell us that we don't have to be
concerned for our children for example
the economy of control tells us some
things are in our control some things
aren't right and so the use of things
the the price it's the way we deal with
them that is in our control
Epictetus ed says that over and over
again how you know how we deal with
things that we've been assigned I've
been assigned by kids in a way and you
know so you see Cicero talking about
this you see seneca i you see it's very
consistent across the board that yeah
well yeah you know in a way I suppose
it's a duty to the rest of the world
that my kids aren't you know terrible to
them yes stronger justification yeah
it says that we should be stuck to
maintain inner tranquility but for the
purposes of civil service so recognizing
that were part of this organism of
humanity
yeah allows it to work in harmony oh
love yeah Seneca even says in on anger
because the stokes have like a zero
tolerance thing about anger but he says
ian on anger that the judge sometimes
needs to appear to be angry so they're
not angry to you know get the person to
do the right thing it might be you might
see that's counseling hypocrisy or
something like that but Seneca sees this
is part of oh he wanted to go into this
I came with him and now I'm totally it
was it turns out to be very useful stuff
you know well I'm probably not gonna
change that and so there's you know do I
have a duty to I don't have a duty to
like tell each person on the street you
know you'd be a better person people
would like you more yeah as a matter of
fact that might make me an obnoxious
if something next to you smells really
bad yeah you can address it with them
and in a way that's not a demolishing
right right and then if they if they
don't then they don't after that this
they're not collecting our money lose
smell bad yeah Epictetus actually has an
entire chapter in the discourses on
cleanliness which seems to be something
that's the body that's outside of our
control he says well you know you don't
have to stink because that may offend
the person next to you so so there is
some some room for this I think
distinguishing what is or isn't better
your control okay we've already started
talking about that that can be very
helpful in the situation I think that a
lot of these these people who are in the
neues will often tie in with this
dynamic where we think things are in our
control but they're not in our control
or we wish that they were we get
invested in the outcome I think about
the drama at king and queen right their
drama is their drama and how things turn
out for them that's their story we
probably you know want to keep a
distance from that but one of the
reasons why they can be a problem for us
as we get suckered and you start taking
their side in things
this is often turn they often turn out
to be the ones who weren't totally
invested in the story - sometimes you're
left holding back yeah
music playing yeah physically rested the
issue is not whether you have to deal
with drama the issue is about whether
you're dealing with a person who is like
chronically engaging in drama so yeah
there could be plenty of legitimate
cases where things that are very
dramatic students are gonna punch each
other that you have to intervene or you
know some drama can off but is often
about relationships a surrogate yeah but
at the same time sometimes at work we
are called to highly tense and dramatic
situations where you have to be
level-headed you cannot completely
disengage them but somehow attract just
distract deescalate and make sure that
the law is followed and no one gets hurt
yeah and that can be a chore sometimes
yeah I mean it's fortunate that is like
when you're teaching philosophy that
doesn't come up all that often in
classes but then you're in your
situation yeah yeah no no I I mean I I
totally understand and there's there's
plenty of things like that especially
you know if you think about it if you're
in a managerial role too you're always
gonna have employees that have a
personality conflicts with each other so
yeah
in the workplace and you've done what
you think is all you can do yeah bring
attention to it and then nothing's
happening is a stoic way to being like
so I thought in my control I have to
find peace with this yeah and there
there's there's not just one strategy
for that I mean in some cases it might
be here's another thing too this is a
bit of a digression but I think it's
important to keep in mind that we're not
sages that we're not the the final end
product of stoicism there is
disagreement about whether the sage even
existed or not the perfect wise person
the perfect virtuous person we don't
have to be that in order to be making
progress to be pro Colt toy right the
Greek word for it but we do have to
write if we're going to recognize that
we have to realize that we only have so
much capacity that although it would be
nice for us to be the sage
I know that if I allow myself to not eat
as I should and I'm very rushed and I
deal with a lot of student nonsense over
the course of a day by the time that I
hit four o'clock I'm probably going to
be a lot more prone to snap at people
people of any sort you know it could be
the guy in front of me in a line could
be a co-worker and and so if I know
that's the case it is still in my
control that I say okay I better go stay
in my office
oh I don't have I don't have any sort of
ideal stoic you know capacity at that
boy had sort of run through my my
capacities and so I think in some cases
in the workplace it would be legitimate
for somebody to say I gotta quit I I
can't take this job
to find another job in other cases if
you can actually you know put up with it
that the key would be to get to the
point where you actually are feeling
okay with the fact that these other
people these knuckleheads that you
brought all this stuff to their
attention and they just are invested in
not seeing the problem and want to do
something else instead that that outcome
is not up to you you can still value
what you've done you can still see it as
positive even though it didn't have a
positive outcome somebody else and the
director there the general sense was
that she was very stern very cold very
professional there's a general feeling
of being afraid of her among the Senate
and because of my philosophy I just did
my best to remind myself that she's
human being I'm human being and I'm just
going to speak to her like that
and what's gonna happen is what's gonna
happen eventually she started making
decisions that were very questionable
and IBM contemplating what can I do in
the situation to try to make it better
I'm really limited in what I can do
because I was just personal Kerry I
wasn't like a teacher or something like
that I had that what I felt was a
respect of the director and the other
staff but only they knew to what extent
that respect was yeah so I approached
the director and I understood that it
was a risk of losing my job and I said
to her that these different decisions
that have been made I will be Eve I
understand why you're making them but
I'm confused so I'm concerned and
list of the reasons why and she said
that she understood but that her hands
were tied because something above her
was telling her to do these things or
how did it how would it look if I do
this thing or not do this thing
yeah and and I said under those
circumstances if things don't improve I
feel as though I need to weep and I and
I have was base and understanding not
because I was afraid of being in the
situation yeah no it was physically
dangerous sometimes to be in that
situation
it was because I felt or had the
impression at least that the other staff
we're going to see me leaving or hear
about me leaving and we're going to base
our decisions off of that whether to
stay or to speak up also as it turns out
they start speaking up after that and
the director of much later sign yeah
that's actually a great point that quite
often when we react in in the workplace
and in broader forms to it in politics
and personal relationships the things
that we do we often see them as just
it's only got the effect of what I do
but but there can be a lot of other
people who derive something from that
and here we're essentially talking about
courage right it takes a lot of courage
to be able to go in and to begin with
and say here's what I think is wrong you
know and and put up with the
consequences of doing that and then I
think it also takes courage sometimes to
you know report somebody to to quit you
know ironically quitting is sometimes
Judas the coward's way out
right but when enough people do things
like that then other people start to get
the message and it's very contingent
though you know they we have to look at
this upper case by case basis I don't
think there's general rules for this
sort of thing right let's talk about it
another one of these picking up things
by the right handle you've all heard
that phrase you know some things you
know things have you picked up by two
handles one of them
you can bear it the other one you can't
bear it Epictetus is using the example
of your brother's jerk do you pick up
the thing by the handle my brother's a
jerk to me therefore I should retaliate
you can't really carry that order you
pick it up by the handle my brother is
my brother I'm gonna treat him as my
brother even though he is a jerk I think
this could be very useful there's a sort
of anomic device this this this picture
of the two handles when you're dealing
with difficult co-workers or bosses the
the key thing about this is that it's up
to us we do have a choice about which
handle week we pick things up by and
there may be some times where there is
no handle you know and then we just have
to leave understanding others without
excusing them this is another key thing
and this ties in with what massimo was
talking about today in terms of a mafia
people do Dom misguided insulting you
know wrongheaded pick whatever you like
things why do they do it is it just
because they want to get you some of
them actually may but in every case
there's always some sort of disconnect
going on they are fundamentally mistaken
about what's good what's true what's
rational and they're behaving the way
that they do because of that it can
sometimes be where they say ok I've
studied my stoic philosophy now I'm
really gonna stick it to you I you know
I understand that I should treat you
nice but now I'm going to deliberately
treat you on they should they're still
laboring under a delusion that that
somehow is what's good for a human being
what's appropriate for that yeah
yes way not excused but the personal
score is that the person I sit next to
at work there was a period earlier in
this year where he'd be really short
would be a very demanding you know her
multiple week period but I found out
later that his wife had recently been
diagnosed with cancer the point is you
never want to excuse things but there
are a certain set of circumstances where
you can kind of understand had one
empathy yeah that they have their own
worries anxieties and hardships that
they're doing in their own life and
thinking that would kind of help me
better deal with those offenses yeah
it's interesting because Epictetus
brings us up in terms of anger he says
in that that thing about the thief right
you come somebody's a thief are they
trying to stick it to you
and Epictetus says don't be angry at
them because the poor master can't help
doing what he's doing right and he goes
on he says if you feel anything towards
them because ideally would you maybe not
feel something feel and what it gets
translated generally it's pity and Lance
better translation for that the
contemporary scene is empathy or
compassion we can feel that towards
towards people and it doesn't excuse
anything that they do doesn't require
saying that what they do is okay it
doesn't require saying that's justified
as a matter of fact you're you're
admitting that they are off base in
doing so yeah how would a situation
where someone is feeling very insecure
and very anxious oh yeah so what they're
doing is
yeah your new bosses are like your
interpretation yeah this goes beyond
stoicism this is something you can say
about emotions in general from a lot of
different philosophical perspectives for
at least some people in many cultures
including our own anger is often a mask
for other emotions there are cases where
people rather than feeling or displaying
fear would much rather have anger some
people do that with sadness rather than
actually they are hurt instead of
experiencing that it's easier to feel
angry because anger has a dynamism
through it anger seduces us into
thinking that we can actually control
things it at least feels like you're
doing something
approaches by virtue of even asking me
question why are they doing that yeah if
you personalized the situation it
becomes about them rather than do you
think it does that if the answer is
because they hate me well let's think
that through
okay I think you're right about them but
sometimes it could like I said it gets
bumped up to a sort of a secondary level
where we can still ask the same question
okay why do they hate me right is it
because there's something despicable in
me no they probably don't know no well
Epictetus says hey you don't like me you
probably don't know me because if you
really knew me then you'd really not
like me right which is as well yeah
that's empathizing so sometimes
psychologists will make a distinction
because empathise with really
loosey-goosey turn these days you know
for a while I have a lotta empathy now
there's people like turning against it
but that's the kind of empathy where you
sort of put yourself in the other
person's place yeah sometimes it can be
tough to do if we have it if we haven't
had enough of a similar experience like
I think you know having kids can be a
good thing for that cuz it's like so
easy to relate to other parents I'll
actually let you in on a secret too so
when you have kids kids misbehave and we
just brought up again you don't want
them to turn out to be rotten for the
rest of the world
one of the most gratifying things and it
shouldn't feel this way about being a
parent and seeing some others some other
parents kids and it's behaving and it's
not your kid for once that's like you
know knocking stuff down in the
supermarket or screaming at the top of
their lungs or to do it whatever and you
feel that moment sit-downs I don't think
it's very strong it's not schadenfreude
it so much which is like taking delight
at somebody else's
badness it's almost like a you know
thank God is them not me
you know it's their problem to do it at
this time and there's probably similar
things reminding yourself of values and
costs of things this is one that I think
isn't that sort of immediately intuitive
but it can be quite useful then whatever
Tina's talks about this he says and this
is tiny and very closely why do people
do the things they do he says everything
has its price and every person has their
currency you want to get somebody to do
something look at how they're motivated
you know this person is motivated by
this thing could be like sexual
attraction of people you have been lit
up as an example could be wanting to
make a buck could be needing to be in
charge remind yourself of what it is
that you actually do value because
you're gonna lose sight of it when you
get ticked off it's really easy to lose
sight oh I didn't say from from
experience right well you decide with
the prices in terms of morality well you
got to decide first what the currency is
and so if you're following this historic
day he's going to be like you know I
think Donald and what it was either
Donald or Bosco was talking about the
scale metaphor if you're really doing
things in stoic when virtue that that's
gonna outweigh it every time so remind
yourself that there are all these
different currencies you're choosing
this one it won't necessarily you know
make it entirely a happy situation for
you but but it helps the bigger picture
perspective that I had in mind here for
another one of these what you can do in
the situations like what Marcus talks
about it's almost summed up in a catch
phrase that we use where you say life is
too short for this life is too short to
be upset about this because Marcus will
say you know anything this is a 60 year
old man of course
doesn't know how much longer he's got
thinking about how much time has passed
how little this little moment that we've
got is in this vast you know course the
stuff that you're getting upset about in
the workplace it does matter it is real
stuff but in terms of the bigger
perspective maybe somebody and we'll use
the chewing thing again maybe somebody
chewing and the cubicle next to me it's
not really that big of a deal
I I don't want to say that like openly
abusive stuff is something that we
should say not that big of a deal I can
I don't have to put up with it
it doesn't have to bother me I don't
think that it's appropriate for that but
I think for many of these other types of
people that we're talking about we can
say you know okay it's in the grand
scheme of things
[Music]
but if I can you know whatever all I
ever you know I if I can just put it off
texts are terrible because we have like
no context when people text us and they
say terrible things to us sometimes you
know whole websites to plan to that like
well so your interesting kind of a
temporal distance yeah you know yeah
good what you said about the bigger
picture reminds me of the almost cliche
you know if attempted to either work
this weekend or spend time with my
family with the cliches how many people
on their deathbed would say they would
spend they spent more time at work yeah
that's true no one there's a there's a
there's a joke that I heard and you may
not find it funny but you may find a
funny
the philosophy teacher told that in
class he was talking about a philologist
philologists where we don't call
classicists right and this full ologist
had spent his entire career researching
two words because that's what a lot of
philologists would do they look at all
the text whereas this word showed up
what what contacts and all that and on
his deathbed they asked him do you have
any regrets he says I do have an regret
now there thought I didn't spend time
with my family because his home life is
all screwed up you know he was just kind
of it
none of it went well he says and wish I
would've only count
because then I would have done it really
well but you're right people like that
are pretty rare yeah I think that that's
a good way to think about it and that
also ties in sort of with that our
currency what is it that we really value
you know sometimes we can say to
ourselves yeah I can put up with these
these peoples BS because this is a
living and it does put food on the table
and maybe it's not that big a deal
sticking up for what's right in the
right ways against something we can do
in the situation one is prudence not
just courage in going in and telling
people that they're wrong or that
something needs to be fixed
you know we also want to be attentive to
justice we don't want to just because
somebody's done something wrong think
that it's okay for us to transgress they
don't become a fair game because of that
so those are all things you can do
within situations and I don't want to
keep you guys over too long but I want
to go through some of these other things
that are sort of longer-term and what I
will do is I won't like hold anybody
here past four because we're supposed to
end at four but I all stick around for
you know Q&A and talking about this so
I'm gonna run through these a little bit
quicker okay well then we got plenty of
time then so all right so examining your
own desires and aversions this is
something that the Stoics you know it's
the discipline of desire it's one of the
key things that you have to study for
figuring out first you got to figure out
what what are you actually desiring what
are you actually diverse averse to not
Dover's to averse to because sometimes
we've actually got that mixed up we can
be an ear about it sometimes we lie to
ourselves about what our desires are and
I think we're probably better off if we
tell ourselves you know things like yeah
I really you know I really do want to
make a ton of money you know if you
think that wanting to make a ton of
money is a bad thing it's it's neither
good nor bad actually from from the
stoic perspective except insofar as it
would like keep us from being just or
courageous or temperate but we're better
we can only work on things if we
actually admit them to ourselves I can't
stand this person but I'm pretending to
like them that's something we gotta
admit to ourselves you know I can't
stand this person because of some you
know irrational aversion that I have to
somebody from childhood who they kind of
look like well we really have to be
honest with ourselves about that or we
can't make any any progress so examining
your sort of panoply of desires and
aversions that's something you can do
and I asked to have them long term this
is why journaling is so useful something
that gets talked about making your
examination lately about how did I do
that we'll start to bring that stuff to
light over time reminding yourself that
you are dealing with people not stones
not robots not other things where you
can like flip switches on and off but
actual other people who have their own
screwed-up sets of desires and aversions
and choices and history yeah
27 years old and I was sitting at which
me hables with my first wife's dad and I
was unloading about something in my life
that was bothering it either yeah and he
said to me he's Cuban said to me you
know what in life everybody has their
own pail of [ __ ] it's got my job to
carry your paper since first of all they
never complain that age
how much anxiety it produces an apparent
sometimes when to hear about all this
stuff it really isn't so bad yeah and in
a workplace for example you know they
caused me to be very reticent about I
don't say I'm standoffish
but you know oversharing mm-hm you know
and because once you start to overshare
everyone else starts to overshare also
you know and it creates a sort of it
that I know so I don't know exactly how
that fits in here but I always like
sharing that story it's a great story I
think that fits in there is good advice
you know we also have that you guys have
all heard that expression at my circus
not my monkeys you know it's the same
sort of deal we often do let ourselves
get sucked into other people's circuses
concerned about their monkeys ya alaikum
in my town right now we're trying to
deal with like a community issue hmm so
we're coming up against the bully
okay so then we occurred like I I'm
pretty enthusiastic person so
you know I don't believe what you're
saying I feel like you're feeding me a
line please tell me what you're gonna do
about this situation
yeah so what he has done is publicly
gone back and say the people are
bullying me like I had gone and I said I
feel like you're your kind of cornering
us and making our community on safe with
these decisions and and that's the case
for then yeah he used that as a platform
for saying he's being bullied now
because the community is trying to make
him accountable trying so I don't know
how to deal with him he's he's he's
actually a bully in real life well he's
used to kind of bullying people around
getting his way so I don't know I I just
wish I had like a tactic to deal with
them and they would well with that first
of all not not not losing your temper is
a big one because already he is setting
things up so that he's setting up a
narrative in which he's the victim right
so if you did you respond by saying how
look at how bad this guy is or something
like that and you do it in any way that
that's like sort of finished with anger
now he's got you already
Oh calm down and I said I say I'm sorry
this is Judiasm I'm in yoga instructor I
don't get angry and then I kept going
without authorization so they didn't get
caught up on that okay now that that's
where they were going with I mean
pointing out that pointing out calmly
them that somebody is really they're
really the bully and that the topic
should be about that one way to do it is
you can say we've got all the time in
the world to talk about how you're being
bullied we're just going to talk about
this first addressing it directly with
them well I mean who do you want - is it
him that you want to try to get to stop
the behavior as he's the roadblock yeah
he's more of a roadblock like it's it's
a good system
and it gets a bureaucracy that is system
choice I mean first off you've got
acknowledged that you may not be able to
get him to change all right so there's
that outcome but sometimes you can go to
people and say look I understand that
you feel like you're the one who's being
bullied but really you're you're
engaging in bullying or so here's how
you're doing it and they may listen to
you that can help sometimes you're
actually making a case not to that
person but other people because we're
trying to get like maybe they're trying
to do an end run around them all right
and in that case I get just making the
case as sort of calmly as you can that
that may that's the best that I think
you can do you don't want to be too
invested in in the outcome this is what
Bill Irvine calls internalizing your
goals and not being so concerned about
the outcome as an example of what the
Stoics do and if you do that you can say
the way we talked you fought the good
fight right you don't control whether
things actually go your way but you put
in you put in the best that you can and
then you can actually this is something
this is another one of these techniques
a little bit later you should feel a
sense of as Epictetus sense you know joy
in your good performance it's not stoic
to not feel joy it's not stoic to like
do the right thing then say they did the
right thing
sucks but you know at least they did the
right thing no you should actually feel
good about having done the right thing
it starts something
and then yeah and again that that is is
prudence practical wisdom I'll bring up
another thing to Cicero I brought up
this book several times on Duty's it
really is a great work in it he talks
about justice and he says that the
virtue of justice doesn't just include
like not breaking the law or not you
know not screwing people over making
you're fulfilling your promises it also
includes this entire realm of what we
would call beneficence or you know
kindness there's a couple different ways
to translate the terms involved there
and it's it's doing good to other people
and sometimes that extends like being
concerned about the things that are that
are affecting them but Cicero gives you
some rules he says you know you don't
want to be beneficent beyond your means
right
so you don't you don't use your you
don't run a credit card bills to do
charity work right that that's not
prudent you don't you're not good to one
person by taking away from another
person and he also says there should be
a sort of proportionality to the people
that we're giving our you know our
goodness to our kindness to it doesn't
mean that we say you know almost guy in
the streets for you you're not connected
with me that he's not saying that he
says that there's sort of things that
are sort of the universal human race we
strangers even foreigners those are
those barbarians you know for the
ancients those barbarians they matter to
what the people who are closest to us
maddewar and here he's just enunciated
you know stoic ethics usually when we
talk about these these things you know
in point a osis it's like well we start
with our family and then we try to
expand it out to the rest of the world
and that's great if we can do that but
you know Heraclius circles also work in
wordly so my coworker may in fact be
somebody who is closer to me than
somebody on the other side of the world
but work friends aren't always friends
they're not family even though employers
try to tell us that we're all one big
happy family we don't have to buy that
thing
that's usually done to get us to work
harder for less and so it's perfectly
legitimate to say at a certain point
I've got this much that I can devote
that is justice for the Stoics so I
think that that's in telling ourselves
that can sometimes you know help us with
the anxiety we might feel or the sadness
that we might feel about our inability
to solve every problem it's not our job
to solve every problem it's our job to
solve the the stuff that we've got you
know again here's a bucket metaphor
you know we each have our own bucket
already and sometimes people would it
put other stuff in there the other thing
with reminding yourself that you deal
with people we don't want to expect
people that actually
than they are you know marcus aurelius
had no problem beginning every day by
saying say to yourself you're gonna run
into a lot of jerks today now was he
being a bad guy by doing that nobody's
being realistic about the kind of people
that we're dealing with working to
gradually change our habits the Stoics
are all about changing habits as they're
anybody who's concerned with virtue
ethics you know whether they're
Aristotelian zorp lateness the Stoics
were very big on that and they give us a
lot of great advice about what we need
to do to change our habits the workplace
offers us great opportunities for doing
that because we're stuck there for hours
and hours and hours a day often doing
the same stuff dealing with the same
people so if we want to change our
habits that's a great opportunity to do
so at least with certain habits I
suppose you know yeah
instead of just doing it each day taking
like one day where you like over the
whole week yeah that that's true and a
lot of successful businesses will engage
in that a lot of times people don't want
to talk about where things have failed
because you know who's gonna get blamed
you know or we don't we don't want to
face up to the fact that we we didn't do
that well but doing a post-mortem about
you know like why a deal went bad that
can often be very very helpful
negative visualization are you guys
familiar with this one sometimes it's
talked about in terms of the
premeditation of Evil's this is actually
quite helpful it's you know sometimes it
seems morbid to people why would you do
well on the bad stuff because if you do
it beforehand it often turns out not to
be so bad and if you notice the Stoics
also tell us don't just think about the
bad stuff and like how crappy it's going
to be think about the resource
you have to deal with it think about how
you would rise to the occasion and and
you know this is one of these things you
have to practice in order to see that it
really does work but it really does in
fact work this is one of the things
interestingly that we keep stats on like
over stoical week and we're starting to
acquire some empirical evidence for the
success of this all thanks primarily to
Tim l'p Lebon our guy here who does all
the stats crunching reminding yourself
of larger part hole relations you if
you're in a workplace you are not just
you
so-and-so who's been hired or maybe who
runs the place you're part of a greater
whole
you know and and that doesn't mean that
you just have to totally subordinate
yourself to her that you don't matter
but it is it is useful sometimes for
getting over dealing with difficult
people to remind yourself that you and
they are part of a workplace or part of
a company or part of a project or part
of a team and that the good of the team
isn't just a matter of the you know the
individuals all doing what they what
they want or sticking up for themselves
they have to harmonize together some
people are much harder to harmonize with
granted right but there there is some
some truth to that
Epictetus says this wonderful example
when he's talking about you know what's
in accordance with nature and what's not
in accordance with nature was a very
complicated subject as it turns out and
he says that if a foot left to its own
device decided things it would never go
in the mud right because why does it
want to get dirty but if it's going to
be a foot if it's going to be an actual
part of a living body well you know it's
not the Isaac on the mud it's the foot
that goes in the mud right and it's the
same way I think with a lot of
workplaces we can say well I don't like
this role maybe we need to switch into
it to a different role but if we're in a
particular role we can choose to do that
well you know if I'm worked a lot of
different jobs over my lifetime if I'm
you know the janitor I can do a good job
making sure the places actually
and not worry about whether people are
using you know too many coffee filters
or things like that that's not really in
my my purview
that's that's somebody else's things I
think it's the office manager to worry
about and so there's a lot of ways in
which we can remind ourselves over time
about this and and our co-workers or
clients or employees or bosses will
become less onerous to us as a result
I'm spending some time with the virtuous
this is can be done in two different
ways and when I say the virtuous I don't
mean again the ideal stoic sage if you
find them you know great I've never
found one myself
and I've been hanging out with these you
know modern stoicism people for quite a
while I'm not one myself you know but
Cicero tells us about this he says when
I talk about virtuous people I don't
mean people who are perfectly virtuous I
mean the people that we actually know
who seem to have you know some
propensity for virtue that have gone
part of the way they're not perfect we
have people like that in our life we can
choose to spend more time with them and
less time with other people who are say
vicious what's the other way we can do
that
besides the the individuals who we know
yeah I don't actually find Socrates
myself particularly helpful I know
everybody loves him but I you know spent
too much time reading platonic dialogues
to be particularly enamored of him
because sometimes he seems like a jerk
to me but but yeah Epictetus you know
marcus aurelius
i would love to hang out with them even
if they you know
Epictetus says you know the the the
philosophy school is sort of like a
doctor's office doctor's office is you
know before they had like painkillers
you came in and they did their thing to
you and it hurt that's the way the the
philosophy teachers school is like I
think I would still go in there and like
hang out with him how do we do that how
do we spend time with epictetus or
marcus aurelius or whoever else you
think is great yeah yeah this is so I am
a producer of YouTube videos I would
much rather people read the books than
watch the videos because I think it's
important to have direct experience with
the people that we're talking about if
it comes down to a choice between the
two always read the book rather than the
secondary source read the original stuff
all of you are up to it all of these
people are available in a variety of
translations sometimes the concepts can
be hard but yeah that's the way with any
anything right yeah
those sort of opportunities I mean we
don't get to do too much of that here
because it's not like a retreat but
those sort of opportunities I think are
really great there are there are many
stoical meetup groups now the stoic
fellowship if you go to their website
they will they'll tell you where the
meetups are and they'll also give you
resources if you want to organize a
meet-up so they're doing really great
work I think that's one thing that you
can do that will will help with that
tracking and reflecting on how you're
doing that
that's a great idea you know the
journaling for some people engaging in
various projects you know writing
projects right I'm pointing at Travis
over here the he's the applying stoicism
guy he's been doing a very interesting
thing charting how you actually apply
some of these things these are all great
ways to you know progress I think you
know the stoic camp itself you know and
things like that were you're doing it
with other people can be quite helpful
and then I mentioned taking joy in your
progress
it is it is stoic to feel joy it's not
stoic to not feel anything so when you
actually do succeed even if the outcome
doesn't look successful but you do
succeed in you know taking one of your
versions and not letting it dominate you
in the situation and doing the right
thing you should feel good about that
you should actually celebrate that I'm
not saying you should go out like you
know have a party they write or toot
your own horn but it is something that
you should feel a sense of satisfaction
and epictetus and Marcus Aurelius and
Seneca and Cicero tell us this so I
think that's authentically stoic and if
you don't do that sort of you know you
might call it self congratulatory self
care it's going to be harder to continue
on with that if you do these these
things you will find people that are
difficult for you in your workplace
getting less difficult to deal with some
of them may always be a pain though
and then if you were starting with that
ah I didn't put that one in there but
yes well I mean if your coworkers are
telling him hey you you really you know
lose your temper a lot or nobody you
know yeah I mean there's there's a
variety of ways to get insight about our
own selves one is to ask other people it
may be tough to get genuine feedback
right especially for like you're let's
say you're the boss or you're the most
important customer of somebody it may be
difficult to get them to say things that
would be offensive this is actually a
very fundamental problem for leadership
it's difficult for leaders to get
feedback from like I work with you know
quite a few CEOs of startups and that a
few CEOs of big companies in some of the
work that I do and this is one of the
things they say is most difficult to get
the employees to actually tell you when
you're doing stuff wrong when your ideas
are stupid or when you've behaved like a
jerk it's it's difficult for them to do
that but I suppose if you create an
environment over time where people are
more willing to give you good feedback
that can help yeah
creating like an organization an idea
nervous you know only two good idea to
win and you know you agree on principle
we codify it if you have a disagreement
that you have to go back to the
principle of it you can't resolve it
there's more than driver genes at school
together
they are you anymore you are you know
even if that doesn't actually work in
practice the way it sounds it's still
better than like well I'm the boss so
it's my way right or the customers are
saying this so we got to respond
immediately and do it this way right
even if you like don't achieve consensus
if you are talking in terms of
principles rather than just you know
hierarchy or personalities or something
like that it works out generally better
you know a lot of that that's a matter
again of prudence right prudence is
rarely realized in its fullness in any
of us most of the virtues are that way
we're not we're not fully courageous
we're not fully just we're not fully
temperate you know but we that we can
certainly make progress towards that and
so things like that can be institutional
ways to to do that
I would be interested to see that I
think that my initial impulses that I'd
be a bit leery of it but yeah yeah
any other questions I don't want to hold
any of you over time I'll stick around
for a bit if you do have any questions
but any last comments is did you find it
helpful or you better prepared for
dealing with the jerks that you got to
deal with okay thanks thanks for
[Applause]